[Music]
so would you board this time I did
here's the thing we got to preface this
whole thing by saying that we took a
stab at this a while back before the
holidays and we had a technical snafu
which happens from time to time although
I would I think it's only happened maybe
two or three times in the seven years
that I've been doing it and it's just
when that happens the pit is my stomach
it's the worst it's the worst feeling so
first of all my apologies for our
technical snafu and thank you so much
for coming back no problem
give me another chance to hang out with
the King I realized where we went wrong
now and and why we had a technical
problem I don't know if you'll remember
this but I did not wear the uniform last
time you were wearing a black t-shirt
and I almost invariably wear a black
t-shirt for the Fahd guests and for some
reason I was wearing something else and
I think that that just threw everything
off the planet off its balance a little
bit so anyway here we are first of all
congratulations on the success of the
Blue Zones kitchen cookbook I mean it's
you know once again there you are at the
top of the top of the bestseller list
it's it's a it's pretty cool to see well
I spent years writing deeply researched
books that were I like to think artfully
crafted when it came to the pros and
only to discover what America really
wants is beautiful pictures and being
recipes that's it right but this is not
an ordinary cookbook I mean this this
unfolds much like one of your
expeditions you know this is this is a
deep dive into these cultures as much as
it is about like here's the thing you
can make in your kitchen well yeah I
cringe at the title cookbook because
actually we tried to make it more like a
250 page National Geographic article so
I wrote the introductions are all
science driven the science of why these
foods are
helping these people make it to a
hundred I I think we have the best
National Geographic photographer in this
genre
David McClain shot all the photos
there's no studio shots there it's all
editorial photography so and the end the
recipes
none of them are recopy down i sat on on
a stool and watch these old ladies cook
and captured the recipes and then sent
them here to Los Angeles actually where
they were corrected and test kitchens
they don't have tablespoons and
measuring cups up you see actual people
or no just my observation yeah
but the thing is this is a 500 year old
food tradition that is disappearing
because in all these Blue Zones they're
the American food culture is coming and
replacing this way of eating that has
produced the statistically longest-lived
people you know 20 year olds aren't
eating like this so I was sitting with
70 80 90 even hundred year olds watching
them cook the foods of their youth so
this is almost say a project of
anthropology yeah as much as you know a
food while creating an historical
document I'd like to think it is in the
15 you've been doing this for 15 years
sort of Blue Zones specific type work
what are the changes that you've seen
specifically within the Blue Zones over
the last decade and a half and which
which ones have been the most impact
impacted by kind of Western development
I'll start with the negative and then
we'll move to the positive so the place
that's been hit the worst is Okinawa
when I first started that I actually
first went there 1999 which was 21 years
ago and our test expedition it was at
the time producing the longest live
people in the history of the world about
60 times more I'm sorry 30 times more
female centenarians in people over 60
then you'd have in the United States and
now it is the least healthy pre fixture
in all of Japan it's got the highest
rates of obesity the highest rates of
diabetes and it is undergone the the
worst degeneration of any of the Blue
Zones
you also see it pretty hit pretty hard
in Nicoya Peninsula of Costa Rica we're
Nicoya itself this place where they have
this beautiful simple elegant three
ingredient recipe that is driving must
have much of their longevity you come
into town now and the first thing you
see is a KFC and it just makes your your
your heart sink and at the same time
longevity is plunging and the chronic
diseases like diabetes and heart disease
that are killing Americans are rising
there and within a half a generation or
so these blue zones will just be part of
the mark I mean it feels like in the
same way that certain neighborhoods
within cities kind of protect their
historical heritage and won't let you
build and you know you have to build to
a certain way or you can't build or you
can't renovate these buildings to
protect and preserve the you know the
the kind of historic nature of them is
it not possible to go to the the
governments of these blue zones and you
know give them some kind of
certification that protects the heritage
there is that even possible or is that
just a weird idea no it's a great idea
and in fact I've met with the presidents
of of Costa Rica and you know now under
the good news is the government there
has proclaimed Nicoya Peninsula the Blue
Zone as a as sort of a national heritage
site which has afforded it protections
for older people and more funding to
help preserve older people in the
cultures of older people you see that
more organically in acharya greece which
is another blue zone the real kind of
tourist industry has has sprouted up
around people interested in longevity so
what you see there is older people we're
in many cultures they're kind of
marginalized they're the heroes they're
the the repositories of wisdom and kind
of the local celebrities especially the
centenarians and in the Blue Zone of
Sardinia and this is where the world's
longest live men come from there are six
villages there and the Moral province
and they're in one of them a place
called Cerullo there's a Blue Zone
Center
and there's one street it's probably 100
meters long and there's like 12
centenarian houses on that 100 meters
and out in front of the house there's
huge post posters photographs of the
centenarians so they're really
celebrating this is a national as a
treasure and in these places there's a
kind of an act of will to you know keep
at bay these these modern influences so
is that the positive side of this coin
when when I asked you that question you
said well I'll start with the negative
yes the positive is in some blue zones
they're seeing what a resource they're
they're older people specifically and
and they're this lifestyle and they're
trying to preserve them both yeah are
you optimistic that they're gonna be
able to kind of preserve and protect the
heritage and and you know the sort of
culture these places no I don't think so
because oh no there might be in sort of
a museum sort of way an effort to do it
but it's I think the the forces of the
the world we live in are too strong the
urge to motorize mechanize engineer out
physical activity out of our lives with
ease and air conditionings and power
tools and kitchen gadgets and
electronics and packaged food and
ultra-processed foods and it's that that
that tsunami is just too powerful I
think to to forward you know point old
traditions to hold up do you have a
favorite blue zone I have two favorites
Korea problems it Korea's where my seems
like the one you keep going back yeah
it's I I go back almost every year my
son got married there Wow and there's a
place called Thais guesthouse in nos
which I like to think is the the center
of the Blue Zones very you know you go
there and you during the day it looks
there you don't see any furniture
there's kind of this empty Terrace and
and and there's nobody around but at
night the that the terrace has a trellis
which is
lit up and you're overlooking the Aegean
Sea and people from the village come in
and you'll get Israelis and Europeans
and and Americans and it tends to be
people are making a life transition and
they all meet on this on this Terrace
and they eat Blue Zones foods and they
drink wine and and during the day they
go out in the fields and they hike and
they they go by the sea and and it's
nice to see this this little place in
the world where you can go find your own
Blue Zone so Tucson is is are these
places because of the work that you've
done now becoming tourist destinations
are there people that seek them out and
want to visit them because they've read
about them in your books or heard about
them they're all tourist destinations
and and for that I think they appreciate
but you know when tourist comes it
creates a you know the problems of its
own but but yes they're all tourist
destinations
I think Nicoya Peninsula of Costa Rica
is most made most embraced Blue Zones so
there's lots of hotels or coming in Blue
Zones and you know you land in the
airport Liberia the first thing you see
is a Blue Zone store Wow and but it's on
the other side of the peninsula from
like where all the fancy hotels are no
it's on the same Peninsula it's just
Nicoya Peninsula it's it's Tamarindo and
people also know of Nocera which is kind
of right Tamarindo is the surf village
place right that's Montezuma Montezuma
is on the southern tip of the Nicoya
Peninsula and more tours anarthas
Tamarindo and that there's what the Four
Seasons is okay and kind of halfway
between or is Samara which is a hypsi
Dipsy beach town and then Nosara which
is kind of a vortex for surfers and for
the yoga it's actually a cool place both
of our cool places that's actually not
the Blue Zone the Blue Zones actually
inland up in the highlands in the
villages and they're the type of
villages where you know tourists drive
through and leaving a cloud of dust and
don't really realize what they see do to
find the Blue Zone
you need to go into people's homes you
need to stop long enough to see detail
and to get a feel for what it's like to
live in these places to see how they
cook to see how they downshift to see
how they live out their purpose to see
how they connect socially there's all
these sort of non-food characteristics
that account for as much of their
longevity as eating beans or tofu yeah I
mean to do that work you would have to
have a lot of emotional intelligence and
a lot of patience you know you you I
mean you're a very charismatic
personable guy you've got to engender
the trust of these people to even get
into the position where they're gonna
allow you to come into their home and
participate in their traditions you do I
was blessed rich with curiosity and and
in a genuine affection for traditional
people's everywhere I mean they
fascinate me so I'm not going in trying
to get the story and get out when I did
that's original work I was spending
months at these places and not know you
know there's one there's a three-day
stretch when I moved in with 102 year
old woman in Okinawa neither of us had a
common language and I just sat and
watched her and what Conant she got up
and down off the floor 40 times in one
day that's like doing 40 squats watched
how she made her breakfast how she stood
up on a stool and was washing her dishes
at certain point she pulled out her
denture and scrubbed them with the same
brush and put a dentures back in but
just saw the sort of constant movement
and the flow of people who came and
visited her and that she sort of toddle
out to her garden and that range of
motion and you don't really get you
can't really just go in and ask them
about their lives and leave because
people don't really remember their lives
to do this project right you have to
live with them and pay attention to the
detail and the nuance and then you can
sort of go into the academic literature
and say to find out well they're doing
this one thing - is there any sort of
academic underpinnings
or evidence for why this would be
yielding longevity so in the example of
that particular woman what does she
think is going on what could I possibly
be doing there would be so interested
yeah I introduced her and I remember it
was a rainy like Tuesday morning and I
took off my shoes and you sort of step
up to she is that one of these stilted
houses and I sat cross-legged on its
tatami mat and we looked each other and
smiled and I knew like one Adi gato I
don't you know I'm one Japanese word I
already got two and then we looked each
other's stared and smiled sat there for
about ten minutes and finally she got
bored got up and went about her day and
I just followed her he's still there I'm
obviously not gonna get rid of them
uh-huh no but no I later on her
granddaughter came and we had a
translated conversation was very nice
well just by way of background in
context for for those people listening
or watching who who are new to kind of
your work I think it would be helpful to
just kind of provide a quick synopsis of
what this whole Blue Zones thing you
know is about it started out as a
National Geographic project to in a
sense reverse engineer longevity
something called the Danish twins study
established that only about 20% of how
long the average person lives is
dictated by genes the other 80% of
something else so the project began by
hiring demographers to find places where
people are living statistically longest
and that alone took two years cost about
a quarter million bucks before I could
even start but you know you don't want
to go to a place that's just hearsay and
and try to distill out lessons so with
demographers we found these these
longevity hotspots which I've dubbed
blue zones and then brought in another
team of experts to find the correlations
and we use the methodology of
anthropology epidemiology to kind of
tease out the common denominators
so we found longevity hotspots in
Okinawa Japan Sardinia Italy in Korea
Greece Nicoya Peninsula of Costa Rica
and not far from here that Loma Linda
California and the seventh-day
adventists and over the past 15 years
I've been studying these cultures in an
in an effort to preserve this
interconnected set of factors that are
common to all these places that are
yielding longevity and the first big
breakthrough was a cover story for
National Geographic secrets the long
life and then came a book Blue Zones
nine lessons for the living longer from
the people living the longest
Blue Zone solution Blue Zones of
happiness and now at a certain point
what really explains longevity is
complex and it's multifactorial but a
certain point I realized that when it
comes to changing your health behaviors
for most Americans the change comes
through their mouth so this idea to do a
Blue Zones kitchen and capture these
recipes in these images was really an
idea - I guess appeal to a wider
spectrum of Americans and kind of lure
them into this this deeper and more
complex prescription for longevity and
it seemingly it's worked right so
amongst these populations none of them
are striving for longevity they're not
thinking about it they're not going to
the gym they're not dieting their
lifestyles are set up in a certain way
that is conducive to them becoming
centenarian right the foods they eat the
manner in which they interact with their
community and and interact you know
throughout their daily lives in a
physical sense all of these things kind
of contribute to this set of parameters
that you have kind of distilled down and
canonized that's right so the I would
say the big Epiphany and it took me 10
years to to make this realization you
know in a mirror
we tend to pursue health we find a diet
or we find an exercise program or we we
get a coach or we get on a supplement
program and we think well we got to find
this program we need to discipline the
focus of mind and and we're going to go
after it you know and the vast majority
90 plus percent of people fail at what
they start at within a year mm-hmm in
Blue Zones
these people are eating mostly
plant-based foods they're moving every
20 minutes or so they're hugely socially
connected they're suffused with purpose
not because they've tried it's because
they're a product of their environment
they live in places where the cheapest
and most accessible foods is peasant
food it's whole grains it's not since
greens its its tubers so and it's
cheapest and most accessible and they
have these time-honored recipes to make
them taste good and their kitchens are
set up so they can make them easily so
of course you're going to eat that see a
lot easier to eat that been you know
travel to a big city and buy processed
foods they don't have these mechanized
conveniences in their houses so they're
not turning to some you know power tool
to do their work they're kneading bread
by hand or grinding corn by by hand
they're doing garden work by hand the
the option to implode into their homes
onto their electronics is in there
because within a day if you not shown up
to the village center or the party or
church somebody's knocking on your door
there's a computer show up yeah the
counter be on there's a certain
expectation and nobody wakes up
wondering what their position is in
their community there's always a very
clear sense of purpose and sense of
responsibility you know that the
Okinawans used this word a key guy
people are starting to use that word a
lot sense of purpose and it really does
make a big difference when it comes to
longevity probably eight extra years of
life expectancy but the per
this experience in Blue Zones isn't the
sort of follow your passion purpose that
we think of in America you know we think
well we we're gonna retire or you know
we get you know we I got some free time
on my hand I'm gonna travel or I'm gonna
play golf or or pursue knitting whatever
it is purpose in Blue Zones is is
spliced with responsibilities so when
when people think of purpose it's always
connected to putting the focus back on
somebody else it's making sure the
younger generation thrives it's it's
making sure that the community is taking
care of making sure certain practices
are preserved
there's always an altruistic element to
purpose in the Blue Zones yeah and a
corresponding aspect of responsibility
right that's right yeah so it's it's
almost a hybrid between purpose and
responsibility right you fuse those two
and that's that's the Blue Zone purpose
right and telescoping up from this
what's really interesting is this
perhaps somewhat counterintuitive notion
that infuses the work that you now do
with cities by virtue of the Blue Zones
project which is kind of a rejection of
human self well in a manner of speaking
to say look you know getting people to
exercise making them feel bad if they
don't even if you incentivize them to do
so whether it's dieting weight loss
whatever all of these kind of health
parameters that underpin how we think
about health and fitness and well-being
in the developed world just don't work
yeah don't work and the solution can be
extracted from these traditional
communities by observing the way that
they live their lives and trying to
create environments that are conducive
to making the right choice yes so you
know it burns me up here in these these
finger-wagging politicians saying that
it's it's individual response but it's
you're a responsible ability to be
healthy
but then you unleash people in the toxic
food environment you know I were I we
blue zone the whole state of Iowa and
there was a lot of sort of local
politicians who were saying well when
doors blue zones but we think it's
mostly individual responsibility how are
you gonna ask a single mother who's
barely making ends meet with with her
10-hour day job to go out into the food
environment where ninety seven out of a
hundred choices are bad and say go find
good choices for your kids I actually
believe that if you're unhealthy and
overweight in this country which is 71
percent of American populations it's not
their fault you you go back to 1970 we
had about a third the rate of obesity we
have today and is that because there
were better exercise programs or people
were more responsible right responsible
in the you know post hippy age nineteen
seventy or because we had better diets
or we're better educated no you know our
environment has changed and the very
clear lesson that we get from Blue Zones
is here's environments that we know are
producing the statistically longest
lived in healthiest populations and when
I say longest live I don't mean they
have better genes that are gonna make
them lived 120 what I am saying is
they're avoiding heart disease cancer
diabetes and dementia the diseases that
for short your life so they're getting
the full ninety five years or so which
is the capacity of the human machine if
you're listening to this right now
your body's right to the to the the
extent we science understands the human
body your body's capacity is ninety five
if you do all the right things these
populations are achieving that ninety
five year mark better than any other
population in the world and they're
doing it because they live in the right
environment right they don't have to go
out of their way to do it it's just
right in front of them so mindless that
is the choice to be made so when you
look at the United States of America I
mean where do we fall on longevity right
now
like xlix yes do like right there with
ya Bangladesh or no we're not that bad
what I mean and it drop the laborers -
yeah it drop it
there's been a little bump upward
because we're seemingly getting this
opioid crisis a little bit under control
but the previous three years we've seen
life expectancy dropped for the first
time in living history first time in a
century since the this the the big flu
epidemic in 1917 so no we're we're going
the wrong direction here and the
percentage of our GDP we spend on
avoidable diseases about three point
seven trillion dollars keeps going up
every year it's it's a statistical
certainty it'll bankrupt our country if
it continues on the trend and it's it's
all because of diseases that that result
because the environment we live in and
when you look at the environment the
culprits that I see are subsidized cheap
processed food suburban sprawl the the
advent of the automobile like there are
there are certain kind of like seismic
forces cultural forces that have kind of
led us to this place like people are
more separated geographically we're
reliant on on our own personal cars
versus public transportation we're not
living in consolidated well-thought-out
urban environments our access to healthy
food creates socio-economic problems and
you know we're dealing with with that so
with that kind of like suburban you know
growth we see the degeneration of inner
cities and thus the the kind of food
deserts that spring up that further
exacerbate that socio economic and
health divide it's a lot like remember
that old experiment if you threw a frog
in boiling water but leap out but if you
threw it in lukewarm water and turned up
the water one degree in a at a time the
desert it would cook the frog that's
kind of what's happening to us
I mean in the 1940s 50s even 60s the
American food and built environment was
actually pretty healthy most people
walked
you know you cooked at home there was a
better balance between animal foods and
plant-based foods having a you know
going out for a hamburger and french
fries was an occasional treat not a
daily event and what's happened is first
of all every city engineer since the
Eisenhower administration has been
taught to build a street that gets as
many cars as possible down it so there's
a sort of you be pervasive mindset in
among city planners that you know we
want to build for cars and traffic so
that starts modified marginalizing the
human it's unsafe there's no decent
sidewalks it's the streets are ugly
they're stressful because cars are
whizzing by there there there are cities
that are trying to reverse that trend
but it's going to take some years our
food environment
ever since Earl Butz Nixon's Secretary
of Agriculture
he made trans trans fats before his time
were used only as an industrial
lubricant he made them a food that's
been a problem but also this system we
have that favors corn soy beans sugar
beets and wheat you know none of those
products are bad by themselves but
they're mostly grown in the service of
feeding other animal feeding animals and
there's too much of it's a very cheap
input so American ingenuity takes these
these cheap core products and they
process them and they add value they
market the heck out of them they strip
them of most of their nutrients and now
the ten billion dollars a year is spent
marketing us things like sugared cereals
and chips and sodas and crackers and and
these things that actually have the
roots and pretty good food but by the
time they get to us they're stripped of
the nutrients and they're metabolically
horrible for us and you can't get away
from them mmm what about the car well we
all need cars but
there's this idea of induced demand what
happens in most cities is there's a
popular part of town cars start to
traffic chokes it and the politician
under pressure does the the intuitive
thing widen the lane or put it to more
lanes in or or make rise the speed limit
from 30 to 50 so cars and what happens
invariably is when you make it easier
for cars it induces the demand for more
cars so you put two more lanes in and
within three to five years those lanes
are full because people say no it's
easier to drive places but when you do
the counterintuitive thing and you
narrow lanes and you slow down traffic
we call it a road diet and you widen the
sidewalks and you make a bike lane which
actually causes cars to slow down even
more at a certain point people do one of
two things they realize wow it's
actually easier for me to walk or take
the bus or bike to these places or the
driving pressure is such that they move
closer to work or they move into a
neighborhood and this happens gradually
we want things to happen overnight but
we could probably eliminate 20 to 25
percent of the obesity problem in this
country if we designed our cities for
human beings and not just cars mm-hmm
and that's a big part of the approach
when you go to these cities and and work
with them to try to create you know a
blue zone certified urban environment
yes how can we create systems to promote
you know human movement over personal
automobiles so let me just give you some
content a context in these blue zones
projects so most of the time when people
think of community health they're trying
to promote diet or exercise programs etc
we don't do any of that we assume that
people are genetically hardwired to
crave sugar fat salt and take rest
whenever they can and instead of trying
to fight that by as you point out and
sent them or guilt they'll name it shame
them we say no we're just gonna set this
these individuals up for success to make
the healthy choice not only the
easy-chair choice but in some cases the
only choice so how do you do that
so in each city I have three teams one
the first team is a policy team and we
have experts on building streets for
humans on changing the food environments
to favor fruits and vegetables over junk
food and to favor the nonsmoker or the
smoker and we don't come in and try to
nanny-state the city government we come
in and say here's a menu of 30
evidence-based policies that have worked
elsewhere to make a city healthier
you've hired us to come in actually the
insurance company hires us to come in we
help them choose from each of these
policy areas eight to ten policies that
would be feasible in that city and
effective in that city and then our
experts help make sure they can
implement it so an example if you live
in a neighborhood where there are more
than six fast-food restaurants in five
hundred five hundred feet from from the
average house the obesity rate in that
neighborhood is about thirty five
percent higher than the same
neighborhood with fewer than three
fast-food restaurants so one of our
proposals is that you limit the number
of licenses for fast-food restaurants if
you live in a neighborhood where there
are billboard advertising for junk food
the obesity rate in that neighborhood is
about 10% higher than the same
neighborhood without billboards ads so
one of the things in our menu is a ban
on billboard advertising and you know
nobody misses the billboard advertising
and lo and behold the obesity rate goes
down in those neighborhoods so we're
gonna try to get eight or ten policies
passed then we have a second team that
administers a Blue Zones certification
program for schools restaurants grocery
stores workplaces and churches and those
it's sort of like LEED certification for
health and then we have a third team
that gets 15% of individuals it's kind
of a tipping point at 15% to take a Blue
Zone pledge and we get them to take
checklists into their home to optimize
their home environment for better eating
and more movement optimize their social
network we create these moais and then
we give them a free purpose workshop
and get them volunteering and if you can
orchestrate the perfect storm people
places and policies and keep enough
energy behind it for five years
in every case obesity drops diabetes
drops life expectancy goes up in
people's life satisfaction as a report
at the gallop goes on mmm-hmm and it's
not because we change individuals or
shamed individuals it's because we
optimize their environment right and the
insurance companies love it they gotta
then the phone rings again dan you're
doing a great job
got a new city for you we're saving so
much money well before yeah our biggest
the Gallup estimates that our project
occasion about a quarter of a billion
dollars a year and avoided health care
cost and that will continue to accrue
because we change and now we're starting
with Orlando Florida mm-hmm Tom sent
them all over there and and the Blue
Cross Blue Shield plan we we got a
blueprint in place for Orlando which is
now three million people is actually at
all Orange County so the the the
challenge gets bigger every time but
it's a it's a worthy challenge yeah and
and you know look we can talk about
plant-based diets and Hickory and stew
and you know planting a garden in your
backyard but first we got to get the
soda machines out of the schools we got
to get people you know walking and
riding their bikes a little bit maybe
not sitting so much you know at their
job like very basic simple things some
of which I would imagine are kind of
easy to implement when you go to these
cities and others
you know perhaps require you know zoning
and and other kind of regulatory changes
in order to implement yeah I see if you
get focused on the Silver Bullet you're
gonna fail we have what we call silver
buckshot
so between our people policy and and
places strategy we probably unleash 80
to 90 long-term nudges and defaults that
are going to favor the healthy choice
over the unhealthy choice we're gonna
fail with twenty or thirty of them but
the others fifty or sixty have enough
influence enough of that sort of Adam
Smith silent hand nudge that we you see
behaviors change and that's the big
secret you know until we have the
courage to take on our environment and
stop with this fairy tale that we're
magically going to get three hundred and
thirty million Americans to a find the
right diet B muster the discipline to
stay on the diet and three have focus of
mine to keep on it for the decades
necessary to avoid a chronic disease
we're not nothing's not then we're not
gonna you know as they say bend the
curve we're not going to do much with
this obesity problem it still we sort of
take on the places we eat are foods
where we go to work our city our city
policies and our food and built
environment where America is going to
continue to spend needless money and
suffer needlessly from chronic disease
yeah I mean I just know it in my own
life we live you know my life is an
embarrassment of riches we live in this
beautiful you know part of the world I
have an incredible view and I'm
surrounded by mountains and sunshine and
you know it's phenomenal but I live very
far from an urban environment so I'm not
doing a lot of walking and I'm also
geographically distant from both most of
my friends and I feel that in my life I
go to New York City
I'm walking from Soho to Midtown I'm
seeing tons of friends in a single day
you know it's it's it's a completely
different experience that is dictated
not because I'm making choices but
because the environment lends itself to
me making different types of choices
that then completely change how I live
my life and experience that day yeah and
they're not even conscious choice right
now where you know if you want a a
bottle of soy milk you got to get in
your car here and right drive but if you
live in New York or you know downtown
Minneapolis like me or Santa Barbara up
the street you can walk to that and it's
just easier to you know walk to the
corner store than it is to and you
probably know the guy in the store
yeah and you run into your neighbors on
the way by and it you know fends off
this other huge toxic
epidemic were suffering America ROM
loneliness which is also shame
friendship in connection is a huge part
of of your work and focus so maybe let's
spend a little time on that well first
of all I think your social connectivity
is much is a function of your
environment as well if you live in a
cul-de-sac and some solace abhart suburb
where there's no sidewalks to the
neighborhood you have to walk on the
street to get the neighbor if you want
to go to a church or or a cafe to have a
cup of coffee you have to get your car
the number of spontaneous social
interactions which may lead to a
connection or a friendship just the
numbers go down by a factor of 10 as
opposed to living in a in a more
population dense walkable community
where people are bumping into potential
friends all the time but in our Blue
Zones project cities you know to our
earlier discussion people are imploding
into their handheld devices and their
iPads and and we have this very
intentional program called moais where
we bring auditoriums of people in and we
actually manually connect them with four
or five other friends helping them
connect on based on shared values shared
interests and shared schedule and then
we just get them walking together for 10
weeks or eating plant-based potlucks
together for 10 weeks and about 60 or 70
percent of the time they stay together
for so far we've been and we'll track
them as much as seven years and so
they're staying together seven years and
we know you are hugely influenced by
your friends so if you're hanging out
with people who are drinking or smoking
your 60 or 70 percent more likely to
drink and smoke yourself whereas if
you're hanging out with people who are
walking every day or are gathering
around great plant-based food those
behaviors are going to become the
contagious that's the same sort of Nod
philosophy that pervades all of our work
Maori is that an Okinawan word moai more
moai it comes from and actually has its
roots in in agricultural past where
there weren't banks so five farmers
would come together and they'd meet
every week and they'd throw in money
every time they met and then when one of
them had a need to buy seed for the next
there was a fund of money that they
could draw from that tradition exists to
this day but it's mostly social and it's
essentially a committed circle of
friends who travel through life together
and support each other when the chips
are down and share when the chips are
bountiful that's beautiful I love that
it's not just about cooking the food
together or participating in a healthy
activity it's the connectivity it's the
it's the the congealing of the group and
the relationships that are yes and it's
a constant thing you know I sat with
five women from the same Moy who get
together every night drink saké argue
about who the hot guy they liked best
back in 1941 is this another one of you
you found your way into the house your
city
yeah I'm sure they have no idea what the
hell I was doing there but they there
ever change is a hundred and two they've
been meeting almost every day for 97
years and you could see that I sat that
with them two nights second night one of
the ladies didn't show up and the other
four put their kimonos on and shuffled
over to their neighbor's house to check
on them so instead of a nurse or some
sort of electronic gadget checking on it
it's this beautiful social construct
that worked without government
intervention or without you know
business getting involved it was you
just you just create it
give it some momentum and inertia can
keep it going for decades if you were
given the task of creating a brand new
city out of whole cloth like there's
just a like a basically a blanket piece
of land and you're charged with
constructing an urban environment you're
the new
you know pierre l'enfant or whatever
looking at how to design washington DC
or whatever it is like what are how do
you begin that process like what is the
city of the future the ultimate Blue
Zone City of the future look like and
and you know how is it kind of oriented
around these principles well I can tell
you when developments are developed at
eye level you know you have this model
and there's somebody looking R up above
down that always fails the design
happens set it has to begin I think at
eye level but it it starts with a core
of minoo you almost look at these sort
of Mexican cities where they have a
zocalo you you want a social square in
the middle of it you know these the
waste cities evolved in in Europe fairly
consistently no matter if you're in
Spain or or Italy or France and or
Greece or it's it's not a coincidence
there's a certain amount of human
ingenuity and and observed wisdom that's
baked into these city designs and in
Europe so you if I had to design a city
right here in the hills outside of Los
Angeles I'd start with a social square
around that I would have restaurants and
cafes outdoor restaurants and cafes I
wouldn't let any cars in that central
area you want mixed-use so people can
live upstairs and they can do their
shopping or the socializing on the first
floor you would have the the streets
would be designed first for humans
I would probably argue in the very
downtown maybe six square blocks there
be no cars at all it would all be
pedestrian but at night cars can come in
and delivery trucks could come in and
deliver food but people don't miss their
cars if if if they if they live close
enough to the places that they socialize
or shop or go to work I would I would
loosen up on the density as you get
towards the periphery but when you see
in all of the happiest and longest lift
cities in America Boulder Colorado
Portland Oregon San Luis Obispo is a
Greenbelt there's a certain sort of
design like a donut and the donut holes
where the people live and the and the
donut itself is places to recreative
places to go hike places to bike so you
you want to keep the development
pressure focused inward and not let it
sprawl outward which is what the mistake
the vast majority of cities make in this
country and you know if you have the
economic influence pointing inward
that's when the ingenuity comes in
there's pressure to make high quality of
life you can't just create huge spaces
and to make better use of the roadways
and the walkways and in the retail space
so of all the cities in the world right
now which city do you think best
captures that ethos like who's doing it
right Oh who's Denmark is doing a great
job which is second biggest city in
Denmark or Copenhagen - I mean they 1970
they had they were choked with traffic
like a lot of American cities are now
over 50% of all trips are taken on
bicycle yeah and this is a cold area and
they did that that didn't come about by
coincidence but it was a slow sort of
pressure gently applied over over
decades to favor the cyclists over the
motorists Santa Barbara right in your
hair they're doing everything right
they're favoring a healthy food
environment they're favoring they've
hired a bicycle coordinator to come in
and make sure that the agenda there's
there's somebody always saying well if
you're gonna design this new Street
there needed to be a pedestrian place
and right other great cities Naples
Florida believe it or not has done a
very good job in the United States
Boulder Colorado yeah one of the best
but they're always intentional they're
always stem from an enlightened group of
leaders who shift their focus away from
just economic development which tends to
be the thrust to quality of life
policies and they just sequentially
bring on quality of life policies and
get them implemented and lo and behold
after about a decade or so you see
obesity plummeting dependably and you
see people's report-it well-being or
life satisfaction go up I was in
Copenhagen last summer I was there right
at midsummer so everybody's out it's
light out you know until 11 o'clock at
night and I was delighted and very
destruction tear lifestyle is compared
to the I was like we just have it all
wrong you know there everyone is
together the cafes are packed bicycles
everywhere people sunning themselves and
jumping them into the waterways and in
boats and it just I don't know it made a
huge impact on me and you said that that
it was once traffic choked so what did
they do
like what happened that they were able
to like make that switch there was an
architect by the name of Yan gal jng EHL
who first I'm one of the first in the
world to realize the importance of
walkability and bikeability and he went
to City Council and he sort of pitched
these ideas for redesigning their
streets so that it favored bikes I mean
it's just literally you start with the
bike lane you slow down traffic if
traffic moves too fast people get killed
you know that if you get hit by a car
going 20 miles an hour your chance of
living are not 90% if you get hit by a
car going 30 miles an hour your chances
of living dropped at 40 percent and if
you get hit by car going 40 miles an
hour your chance of living drops at ten
percent so there's this
sort of playbook where you look at the
streets through the lens of a cyclist
calming traffic narrowing car lanes
creating a protected bike lane trees
make a huge difference
people like to walk on streets where
there are trees so it's minimizing the
noise minimizing that the stress
minimizing the danger and maximizing the
aesthetics and people come and
Copenhagen just did that systematically
over the course of 40 years and so quite
frankly as Boulder Colorado and
something so peaceful
yeah aren't there all these crazy
Studies on sidewalks like just how wide
they need to be or how tall the lip on
the curb needs to be in order to kind of
make it as conducive as possible to
people making use of them yes yes so
well in as a rule you want a sidewalk as
wide enough to get a outdoor cafe on
there if you're in a city yes if if
there is a Dane if one dangerous curb or
one dangerous intersection even though
you might have a perfect sidewalk but
one dangerous intersection and you have
you know some old lady who would
normally walk to church that way but
there's that one dangerous place they
will walk so you really do need to have
an expert who knows how to assess the
whole built environment and think of it
as a whole continuum we have a guy on
our team named Dan burden who is a
direct descendant of that young Galen in
Copenhagen so he he he knows all these
techniques and he's developed them over
40 years it's it's kind of a new science
and it's counterintuitive because most
engineers want more traffic but when you
sit down and listen to him and you see
the results of a walkable City over a
city that's that's um overwhelmed with
automobiles like Los Angeles the quality
of life is just vastly different yeah I
mean what about you know making space
for community gardens like all these
these things where people can come
together and participate in a
activity grow their own food together
right in an urban environment what would
happen if if Manhattan outlawed all cars
except for perhaps delivery vehicles or
you know a certain limited number of
taxis and really amped up the public
transport what would happen to that city
how would it transform there would be
there would be two or three years of
getting used to it and then they
wouldn't miss the chaos at first I would
yeah yeah I mean you have sort of you
know people who can't walk eight blocks
not being able to hail a cab to get to
work but then I think it they would they
would be replaced by these serve
rickshaw cyclists which you see going up
and down Avenue of the Americas all the
time we would adapt I don't I don't I
think more people would take the subway
you know if you just so singapore does
this Singapore Singapore is far more
densely populated than New York City
Singapore's number two in the world with
the highest population density no
traffic problem at all why because they
they only allow a fixed number of
permits to drive and those permits are
available via auction so they get really
expensive gas is two-and-a-half times
more expensive there than it is here and
then they they take the money that these
programs generate and they invest in
this world-class subway system that's
clean and it's on-time and it's safe and
it's pleasant and it's comfortable and
people don't you don't miss their cars
because it's a lot easier faster safer
and fun to get in subway or just walk a
countervailing innovation though that I
would imagine is undermining this is the
the growth of all of these semi human
powered electric vehicles like Electric
skateboards and electric boosted
bicycles like now it seems like you can
get an electric motor in almost every
transportation that used to be human
power so people aren't really riding
bikes they're they're riding things that
look like bikes but actually are Oh
for people who own an e-bike actually
get more exercise than people on a bike
do they because at least they get out
they're getting out yeah yeah they get
on a more and ebike you know I'm I own
seven of them so they can be a workout
bikes
yeah yeah you know you know the you know
the formula for the ideal number of
bicycles rich what however many houses
you have no no no it's it's n plus one
and being the number of bikes you
currently own Oh I said oh yeah cyclist
joke should be everybody's joke right
but but e bikes you know you get
physical activity just it's just not
necessarily it you know in Santa Barbara
I live five switchbacks up from downtown
and you know you never got to eat and
then you know do this mountain goat or
bike ride back home but I can flick on
my eAssist and I'll actually use my bike
now to go out to dinner I think because
I can I can you know it flattens it out
for the write-back you still have to
pedal but just not as easy I'm a huge
fan of e bikes
yeah I've never ridden one a treat
awaits well I don't know you got seven
so maybe when you look at these Blue
Zones pillars you know movement plant
based plant slant diet faith friendship
connectivity all of these things is are
they are they relatively evenly balanced
they're certainly independent they're
they're interdependent with each other
but is there one that stands out it you
know did you write this Blue Zones
kitchen book because the diet component
of it is so important or how do you
think about how the interplay of all of
those yes to your point it is a mutually
supporting web of factors so people eat
wisely they move naturally every 20
minutes because their life is
underpinned with purpose they have a
social network that makes this easy
their friends are doing these things and
they live in environments where the
healthy choice is the easy choice so
they are definitely connected but the
most important variable
there is eating Americans probably lose
six years of life expectancy eating the
standard American diet this is that
middle age by the way overeating say a
Blue Zones diet which is largely beans
whole grains greens nuts and tubers you
know in fruits and vegetables as well so
the problem is except for a few people
like you with heroic discipline and a
great community supporting you it's very
hard for Americans to go plant-based and
within a whole food plant-based by the
way it's not you know Twinkies and chips
you need to it's whole Whole Foods
plant-based diet is the most important
factor but the only way to do that for
the decades necessary to avoid a chronic
disease is have the right social network
live in the right place having that
sense of purpose where it's important
enough for you to be around that you're
gonna make the sacrifices every
occasionally to you know not order the
hamburger yeah also in this is is stuff
about you know portion size time of day
when to eat like one of the things you
noticed is like well the size of the
plates that these people are using you
know is this different than in America
and how does that dictate long term how
we you know so I'll spit out a couple of
the insights captured for Blue Zones
kitchen on how they eat first of all
they're cooking no matter where you go
they're only using about 20 recipes or
20 ingredients rather over and over and
over because they know how to combine
these ingredients to create a symphonic
deliciousness but not a not a ton of
different crazy foods or super foods no
super foods except for beans beans it's
probably the superfood number two they
tend to consume all their food and about
an eight-hour window breakfast like a
king lunch like a prince dinner like a
pauper number three they tend to say say
something before the meal that marks a
punctuation between their busy life and
now we're slowing down to eat like a
prayer and the Adventists or the
Sardinians or Hara Hachi Bou which is an
confused
adage that the Okinawans say before
every meal to remind themselves to stop
eating when their stomachs are 80% full
they tend to eat with their family they
tend to not have electronics in their
kitchen so they're not eating to their
favorite song or eating to their
favorite TV show they they tend to cook
at home as opposed to going out these
are all things that I I would argue add
to the ecosystem of eating that produces
long live people and the core of which
being this this make knowing how to make
plant-based food tastes delicious
hmm to me the most interesting Blue Zone
is Loma Linda because when you look at
the other ones they they are they've
just sort of matured over time as a
product of this environment you know the
surrounding environment contributed to
that
whereas Loma Linda is in contradiction
to the surprise you know so it's almost
more it's it's so much more impressive
to me that they've been able to do this
you know
in the context of you know where you
find this city and that presents the
great hope doesn't it because that's
exactly right because if they can do it
well yeah they live you you know to get
there from here you drive down Highway
10 which is six lanes often under a call
to smog you exit at Loma Linda and the
first thing you see is a Wiener Hut and
a del Taco and it's like what this is a
Blue Zone but you go inland a little bit
and you see this community of
seventh-day Adventists and they're
they're conservative Methodists who
evangelize with health and they
celebrate their their Sabbath on
Saturday not Sunday
which makes them you know the other Blue
Zones are kind of geographically remote
these guys are a little bit culturally
remote because you know the kids aren't
playing football on Friday night or
going to dances and Saturday they're you
know focusing on their religion and
doing nature walks but it shows a few
things number one that your social
network the people you hang out with has
the biggest influence on your health
behaviors than anything else there
with people who other vegetarians you
know they get their diet drunk from the
Bible Genesis chapter 1 every plant that
bears seed every tree that bears fruit
so they're eating mostly a plant-based
diet they're a deeply spiritual they
hardwired right in their religion is a
nature walk on Saturday afternoon so
because of this environment that that's
created around their religion they are
living seven to ten years longer than
the rest of us and we know that
demographically but it just goes to show
you don't have to be an Adventist to to
get this benefit you you proactively
curate a group of four or five friends
you know you want one rich roll out
there who gets you running and you you
want a friend or two as a vegan or
vegetarian because when you're hanging
out with them you're gonna be learning
how to eat plant-based food and you want
two or three friends who when you have a
crappy day like we all do you can call
them and they'll care about you and of
course vice versa and it's it's this
building an Adventist like I think
social network is a takeaway you got to
make your moai that's right right yeah
so I'm just imagining somebody who's
listening to this who lives somewhere
where they're like I don't I've never
met anyone who you know eats that way or
aspires to live any differently than
than how we live like how does somebody
who finds themselves perhaps you know
geographically you know just going from
these the ideas you know and and and and
can't find that in their own community
like how does that person proceed I
guess they can they can at least start
making the food out of your cookbook yes
those kitchens a started place well
first I would think about getting very
clear on what my passions are what I
like to do and what I'm good at and once
you're clear on those those three things
I would volunteer when you show up in a
volunteer first of all we know that
volunteers are happier than non
volunteers but also you tend to meet
other people who are passion driven and
that's a good pool from which to make
new friends
service minded service minded people and
you know if you're a dog person you
volunteer for the Humane Society and you
walk dogs with other dog lovers you know
and people who love animals are more
likely to be plant-based you know more
likely to not eat animals then then then
then you know people who shoot animals
for example but I would find the
vegetarian restaurants and try those or
the vegan restaurants and try those in a
community and then I would you know
actually have a tool on the Blue Zones
website that allows you to go through
your social network you know if we
really take kind of inventory and the
friends we have in our lives and this
inventory actually asks the questions
about how active they are what kind of
food they eat what their temperament is
we often don't do that we often just you
know phone rings and you know our buddy
Jim come on down to the bar you know
we're meeting and you just sort of
follow inertia as opposed to sort of
proactively looking back in your own
group of friends to find the ones who
are going to help propel healthier
habits than the other like during this
inventory of one's relationships and
going holy [ __ ] I could just see the red
pants like snow being a product of your
environment like holy cow look these are
the people I'm hanging out with like
well rich let me ask you I mean you I've
you have this terrific history and you
know your New York days where you were a
big partier and a different that I mean
I I have to guess you left the lot of
the pals you were hanging around then
behind well yeah I mean in in in 12-step
they they call them lower companions I
had plenty of lower companions but I
also like I have like when I was in New
York I liked a lot of that was fun like
it a lot of the people I was running
around with are like really cool people
they just didn't have the problem that I
did and I'm still friends with those
people but certainly you know when that
when that like addiction thing turns and
it starts getting dark you find yourself
spending time
with you know not the better not not the
greatest crowd of people so yeah when I
got sober I had to like completely
change my environment and I invested in
the 12-step community here in LA and I
knew I was like I need new friends you
know I got a whole new set of friends
because left to my own devices that
phone is gonna ring and somebody's gonna
say hey we're doing this and that's what
I'm gonna go do exactly so I had to in
in my own unconscious
you know semi blue zone way I suppose
had to like reconfigure my environment
without moving geographically but
socially well and and that's the other
thing I mean making new friends is is a
it's probably the the most powerful
thing you can do to improve your
happiness and your longevity and there's
actually very good research around the
impactive of the people you hang out
with but the other thing is you say well
without moving your geography probably
the most powerful thing to do if you're
unhappy is move to a happier place and
we know that by following immigrants
from unhappy places like Moldavia or
unhappy places in Africa in Southeast
Asia when they move to Denmark very
happy place or Canada a very happy place
within one year their age doesn't change
much their education level doesn't
change their sex doesn't change their
marital status status usually doesn't
change their their sexual preference
doesn't change nothing about them
changes but within one year they start
reporting the happiness level of their
adoptive happy homes and that often
represents a doubling of happiness so
you know if you're not happy where
you're living when you think about it
what's more important than the health
and happiness of you and your family
you ought to really think about moving
and you know I was on this Mel Robbins
show this week I know taped it just kind
of mine cool just a kick in the pants
yeah she has shed a lot of energy she
does your TV show yeah oh cool yeah it's
good yeah
soon but but at the end of the I was on
there the whole show and they they
brought out three divorced women you
know we're having a really tough time
and one of the women is you know 57 or
her husband at 30 years did kind of a
crappy thing and you know ran off with
another woman left her in this house and
it's a house on the beach you know she
kept saying it's a beautiful house on
the beach but it's really isolated and
she can't find new friends and and she's
really lonely and and I said to her
probably the best thing is move away
from this house where you have at least
30 years of memories with this guy who
did this you know crappy thing to you
and move into a community where there's
other people like you homophony we like
people like us where you can walk places
you know instead of trying to find a
pill or you know even like joining a
club or something like that move you
know that's the biggest most powerful
thing you can do is so counterintuitive
the average American moves 10 times in
his or her adult life so it's not like
something we don't do but we I think we
under celebrate the power of it yeah I
think that's great advice I would I
would add one caveat to that which is is
another thing I've learned in sobriety
like alcoholics and addicts love to move
see I didn't know that yeah well first
of all you know because they burned a
bunch of bridges so they gotta get out
of Dodge but there is this sort of
perverted idea that that moving your
geographic location is going to save
your problems like if you're if you have
some kind of emotional you know disorder
or situation or addiction moving your
geographic location is not going to
solve that because you the thing the
thing that you don't realize is you
bring yourself with you so you got to
kind of work on that as well but I other
than that I agree with everything yes
it's it's not going to change the person
you are in the inside and if you're
addicted or you know emotionally trouble
moving it's not necessarily going to
address that but it's gonna if you're
just a normal person struggling with
normal things I would argue even a mild
depression and anxiety can be
ameliorate it by moving and it's one of
these things that it's it just stacks
the deck in favor of a better life it
doesn't promise a better life it's not
going to release all of your demons it
just put you an environment where you're
more likely to bump into people you're
more likely to get physical activity
you're more likely gonna socialise and
you know everybody else is gonna come on
and say I got this product that's gonna
help you and I'm gonna say forget all
the damn products I'm this sort of aha
the disrupter and say no it's it's it's
not your behavior it's your environment
what did what did Mel say when you
offered up that advice on the show she
liked it actually she let me go on and
on you know she's got this count to five
all right stretch our second rule the
five second rule which is not just for
dropping your toast on the floor but
apparently whenever you're stressed out
or or you count to five and what I love
about her show is as she so many
Americans are struggling over half
Americans don't have 400 hours saved and
she brings him on her show and she's
trying to you know not the dazzling
celebrities she's trying to bring on I
think she's trying to address a growing
number of people in this country are
suffering and you know doing the best
she can in an education I mean a
entertainment format but nevertheless
you know there's a true caring on her
part and a marshalling of the available
expertise yeah a hundred percent I mean
she she has an incredible talent and
facility for being able to communicate
inspirational practical ideas to that
certain type of person who is suffering
in that way and I I think it's profound
like yeah very talented what she does
she's great um so I'm interested in you
know we were talking about happiness
like if you're not happy move so much of
the work that you've done you know we've
talked about blue the Blue Zones of
longevity but you've also spent a lot of
time working on
these blue zones of happiness and in the
Venn diagram of longevity and happiness
very much overlaps but it doesn't
overlap completely nothing of itself is
interesting yeah if you can if you can
situate your life so you're among the
20% of the happiest people in America
it's worth about six years of life
expectancy over being in the least happy
20 percent so they're highly correlated
it's very hard to be happy if you're not
healthy and vice versa
and the blue zones of longevity by the
way are in the top 10 percent of the
happiest places in the world but the
places I profiled for blue zones of
happiness are different places and my
once again my approach unhappiness is if
you want to be happier don't try to
change your behavior you'll fail and
you're probably you you become a
neurotic because none of these
interventions Muslim don't work and the
ones that work don't work for long
enough to make a real life change
difference once again I are you changing
your environment happiness itself as a
meaningless term because you can't
measure it but social scientists can
measure life satisfaction which is how
you look at your life in the rearview
mirror and scale one to ten how
satisfied are you with your life and you
can think of your whole life and yeah
you know I got a good job give it a
number then there's how you experience
your life which is how often you smile
and and fell join the last 24 hours and
then the third one is purpose how often
do you get to use your strengths to do
what you do best
and those three strands come together
and they weave together to make what I
think is a of a rope of sustainable
happiness so I found the statistically
happiest place in each of those three
areas and then I went and told their
story in an effort to marshal in the
science and blue zones of happiness is
really because we have so much data now
it was really trying to tell a
character-driven story of places that
represent
so then other words the things you can
do that stack the deck in favor of
happiness and how do those where do
those diverge from the pillars of the
Blue Zones on longevity I don't think
they necessarily diverge I mean there's
so much overlap for example we know that
people are eating six servings of
vegetables every day they're not only
living longer but they're also reporting
20% more happiness people have a strong
social network arguably the biggest
thing you can do for happiness also
favors your longevity having a sense of
purpose purpose is one of the pillars we
measure when it comes to happiness so
the best crossover in the world is Costa
Rica so Costa Rica's home to not only
Nicoya which is a longevity Blue Zone
but cartago which is up in the mountains
near San Jose which is a Happiness Blue
Zone mm-hmm and Costa Rica interestingly
produces more you know there's a
correlation between GDP so generally the
richer the country the happier it is to
a point but it's not the whole picture
right but Costa Rica produces more human
happiness per GDP dollar than anyplace
in the world and it produces more health
per healthcare dollar than any place in
the world so it demonstrates that when
it comes to happiness and longevity
money's not that important it's not
nearly as important as we think here in
the United States you need secure it's
it's sort of security over prosperity
well it's they they focus on the things
that really lead to happiness
so if happiness were a cake recipe the
important greedy ins so you need food
you need shelter
you need some health care those all cost
some money you need some education
flattens off after about two years of
college so you don't not everybody needs
a college degree trusting environment is
really important having the right
partner in life having a job with
meaningful work the feeling of giving
back these are all men
herbal ingredients and the happiness and
move you know if you're where you live
is the one with the biggest variance so
cartago the happiest places for example
people are socially interacting between
six and seven hours a day and not on
Facebook not on social media they are
sitting across the table from their
friend or so the place I profiled in
Qatar toggle was the Central Market
these these produce salesmen and it has
the air of a bunch of 50 year old frat
boys in a way and frat girls that's it's
a they kind of tease each other they
they help out each other they joke
around when when somebody gets sick they
all pitch in to help for that person the
cheapest and healthiest foods are the
plant-based foods they that they sell
they live on walkable distance from home
they have easy access to nature these
are all things that are gonna favour
happiness they're not gonna guarantee
happiness they're so at odds with with
everything that we've kind of you know
premise to our American Dream upon you
know the idea of like you get a house in
the suburbs and you got two cars in the
garage and you got the job downtown and
you're you know you're just everything
you don't like you're climbing the
corporate ladder and it's about getting
ahead and that promotion and the two
weeks off and putting the money aside
for the retirement there is nothing
about that that speaks to what we
actually have what you have actually
discovered and know about what makes
people live long and live happily that's
exactly right
well when it comes to happiness most
people in this country are misguided or
just plain wrong and it's not because
they're stupid but because we're
relentlessly marketed this idea that if
we have more if we look better if we're
younger if we could just get this one
thing financial freedom did better look
in partner a bigger house that that's
going to deliver the happiness and
that's always misguided happiness is
always a cluster of factors that need to
come together it's never just one thing
and we miss calculate the amount of
happiness
anyone goal is gonna give by about 50%
so in other words this thing we think we
want we're wrong half the time yeah well
the thing is then you we're constantly
being presented with evidence that we're
wrong right like when you get that job
or that promotion or that car or that
vacation you have that kind of momentary
you know excitement around it or sense
of feeling good but it so quickly fades
and rather than challenging the whole
setup or dynamic we say well yeah that
wore off but like I just need to get
that next want to get the next thing
yeah it's not bad to have goals but it's
bad to think that that to rely wholly on
that goal and sacrifice too much let's
just take the context of a day and I'll
tell you exactly what statistically the
the things that you can do that plant
that stack the deck in your favor for
happiness
first of all wake up without an alarm
the happiest people are sleeping between
eight and nine and a half hours a day if
you're sleeping six hours you're about
30% less happy number two eat a
plant-based breakfast if you eat a big
fatty breakfast or sugar cereal
breakfast you're gonna you're gonna be
hungry midday you're gonna have less
energy throughout the day now number
three make sure but you you have coffee
with a friend you have lunch with a
friend you want to make sure to engineer
in four or five hours or six if you can
of social interaction with people you
like volunteer find a little time to
give back every day worldwide
statistically speaking volunteers are
happier than non volunteers take a nap
work part time instead of part full-time
we know from every place in the world
people are working less than about
thirty-five hours a week they report the
highest level happiest of course you
need to make enough money to cover your
basic needs belonging to a faith it
doesn't matter what the faith is but
belonging to faith stacks the deck in
favor of happiness watching TV and
social media it seems at about thirty
minutes a day of each is optimal
actually that provides a little bit more
happy
the no social media no TV at all but
after about an hour and a half of either
one of those your happiness starts to
drop off the drop off a cliff so you
don't you want to spend about an hour a
day exercising at least and that can be
somebody as simple as walking in
gardening or it could be you know like
you do you know running a mini marathon
every day but doing those things are
gonna stack the deck in favor of
happiness way more than shooting for
this financial freedom or you know I
want a house in Beverly Hills or I'm
gonna get that promotion damn it no
matter what it takes
wrong-minded yeah where does risk come
into this like you're somebody who who
very early on you know developed a
certain kind of relationship with
adventure and exploration and risk that
that is somewhat unusual in our culture
and has kind of birthed this career that
you're on most people I would
characterize as you know more fear-based
and and risk-averse in terms of trying
to find that purpose in your life and
and and the sort of willingness required
to place yourself in uncomfortable
unpredictable situations like how do you
think about that in the context of of
happiness well I go on expeditions not
adventures and I never have much respect
for the sort of the adventure
risk-taking I know if you google you
it's like National Geographic Explorer
yeah I'm like I want to be like back
that's like the coolest job title ever
it is pretty cool like listen you know
you've been on the show a number of
times the first time you came on you
went into detail on on this previous
chapter of your life where you said
Guinness World Records for for endurance
cycling and you've ridden your bike and
you've done a lot of other stuff prior
to this so I would characterize you as
an explorer thank you I am an explorer
but not an adventurer you know even
though I biked across Africa I biked
Alaska Argentina I biked around the
world through the Soviet Union the
collapse right after I left and I'd like
to spend three days with a hundred and
two-year-old woman yes it's like that I
would I think that's an adventure it is
but you know it they they weren't risks
we're all very carefully planned out and
calculated to mitigate risk at every but
every Explorer and an adventurer says
that Alex Honnold sat across from me and
said like he doesn't think of what he
does as being risky because the people
there you've done so much work ahead of
time to prepare for that kind of thing I
think what's more risky is sitting in
front of your TV and eating hot dogs and
chips because that that will amount to a
certain death and probably a certain you
know kind of misery through life or each
but I think rather than risk I've been
blessed with this irrational optimism
that you know you can do these things
that most people don't think about doing
or in fact you know people try to
dissuade me from doing them but very few
of them require any risk but in terms of
of how you think about finding your
purpose right like you have to you have
to be willing to try new things and and
perhaps even cut against the grain if
you're in search of what that might be
that will lead you to your you know iki
guy yes
well I think it's a fairly simple
exercise to take a piece of paper and
people haven't reflected on this most
Americans have never reflected on this
you you put four columns yes all the
things that you love to do then right
next to it seem like your passions what
you're good at and then you look at the
commonalities on where where your gifts
are where can you put these passions and
skills to work and once you're clear on
that
if you then design your career around
those the intersection of those and
things you're setting yourself up for
success in life not because you're going
to enjoy the journey and you know it's
we doing what we love we're more likely
to be successful it's like your podcast
I remember you know first time we met
you came over to my house with
the little tape recorder right I got
this podcast I didn't know what it was
it you know and sounded like you know
something you keep makeup in or
something but anyway the the and you've
you've grown it into this Empire and I
know enough about you that you're living
your passion every day by not only
talking about your ultra-endurance but
also using the life lessons you've
learned in the life lessons of the
people you bring onto better people
lives and lo and behold grows so it's
it's it's getting clearer on your
purpose and and and then going from
there
I think it I think it also is about you
know finding that thing that you click
with it you connect with that that you
not only have some kind of natural
affinity for but also has been a
transformative influence in your life
and then figuring out a way to translate
that in service to others to perhaps
have a positive impact that's right at
large that's what I've heard you speak
about that in so many words before that
service to others is really important
too because if it's just a selfish
pursuit it rings hollow after all well
that's I mean I think that's the this
the secret sauce of happiness and it's
so counterintuitive because we're in a
selfish culture where we're taught that
happiness is a direct result of pursuing
what's ours or accumulating but in truth
when you can transcend your ego get
outside yourself and invest yourself in
somebody else's problem or issue all
your [ __ ] tends to evaporate and you
find yourself more present grounded
grateful all of the things that we're
seeking in wrongheaded ways come by
virtue of doing that I've heard it's
often I'm saying that to remind myself
yeah my natural inclination I've heard
it summed up really elegantly this so
the four key ingredients to happiness
are someone to love something to do
something to look forward to and
something to give back mmm you know if
you can get those sort of four things
and do your daily life you're you're
you're pretty well set up that's pretty
good I think
good place that I'll take pretty good
out a pretty good rich role what's your
favorite recipe in the Blue Zones
kitchen book it's the Middle East
minestrone so I met the longest-lived
family in the history of the world nine
siblings Collective aged 861 years every
day of their life they had the same
lunch a sourdough bread a small two or
three ounces of bread konanov wine in
this minestrone which is made from
black-eyed peas lentil beans garbanzo
beans cruciferous vegetables onions
garlic tomato a little bit of olive oil
some pasta and together it creates this
absolute longevity stew that's an
absolute feast for our microbiome and
it's it's also dill it freezes well it's
delicious I fed that to an entire city
Elbert Lee Minnesota
I made 2,500 dishes and this was a
meatpacking plant city and their
definition of vegetables before this
this minestrone was like the orange flex
and Hamburger Helper and I had to I had
to boiling cauldrons of in this in this
city ate every last drop that's cool
that's amazing so you're working now
you've worked now with like over 40
cities right 5050 yeah we just hit 50
cities today Orlando Florida is the big
city coming on in Jacksonville Austin
Texas there with our buddies at Whole
Foods nice that's exciting man how many
people are working for Blue Zones now
about 200 yeah so it's grown so is that
like looking forward over 2020 is that
occupying most of your time I mean I
know you do a lot of public speaking and
the like like what's on tap for you yeah
and we started out with an idea and now
it's grown and and the challenge now is
scaling this and and bringing enough
notch talent so it's it's almost like an
adventure of sorts to build this this
team so that it can handle the size of
the cities that are inviting us in and
you're working on another book not yet
I'm taking a break
I have to do one more edition of Blue
Zones and we think there might be one
more Blue Zone and I'm I'm I'm trying to
confirm that if I do all come out with
another story in Geographic and a super
secret super secret wow that's exciting
yeah if it is our guarantee it's the
last one on earth you've milked this
thing for a lot of books my friend I
don't know it's amazing work how's Kathy
is she good
Kathy Fresa my cruciferous girlfriend
who says hi she's the vegan vixen you
know she's been a great influence on you
know really an early pioneer and making
plant-based eating cool yeah sure yeah
huge huge influence on mainstreaming
what we now kind of almost take for
granted like Oh vegan options pretty
much everywhere you go but like Kathy
played a huge party yeah you got Oprah
to go vegan for a while and uh Ellen
DeGeneres and cross world kitchens which
I argue is one of the best restaurants
in Los Angeles is all plant based off
that would have been seen as a heresy
yeah 15 years ago what kind of a also a
big influence on you personally like I
think even in the time that I've known
you you had an evolution in terms of of
your plant-based diet you know
relationship yeah you know I I come I've
come to a plant-based diet by observing
that the diets of the world's longest
said people and 95% of what they put in
their mouth is whole plant-based food
but she comes at it you know sort of the
animal cruelty and I never even thought
of you know that the occasional piece of
meat I ate occasioned you know this just
horrible pain and suffering from another
sentient being my favorite statistic she
told me that an adult pig
has the intelligence of a three-year-old
human it spends its entire life in a
cage it can't turn around and lives in
its own feces connects with its its
young the same way we connect with our
young wants to socialize feels pain in
the same way yet lives a miserable life
and has a horrible death at the end all
in the service of you know bacon or pork
chop and it's you know when you add that
to the fact that you know eating a
plant-based diet is probably worse six
to eight years over eating a standard
American diet it's just so
overwhelmingly right to that not to
can't afford a environmental considering
yeah it's the third prong yeah yes yeah
well we got to round this out here I
just want to say for the record and
publicly that you have been a huge
inspiration to me
and a bit of a mentor I appreciate you
as an individual as a human being as a
friend and I have so much respect for
the work that you are doing and will
continue to do you are truly changing
millions of lives and the ripple effect
of that will be seen for generations to
come because of what you're doing in
these cities and it's really no small
thing I mean you've you've basically
created a term that has entered the
modern lexicon like everybody knows what
the blue zones are right now and it
starts with you and so thank you for
that you're a gift to humanity oh well
very glad to have you in my life brother
from another mother I consider you the
core of my mind and solidify that so
thanks man thank you for the kind words
welcome back any time and I think that
we before you get recorded I think we're
good all right peace
[Music]
you